The mayor of London has the budget for all of London
and that's a minimum of £17 billion a year.
So, every home that's being built,
all of the met policing budget,
the fire brigade all of these things are led by the mayor and the GLA,
which is the Greater London Authority.
The mayor sets strategy others than deliver.
So, when you look at a lever for actually delivering change,
people say the mayor doesn't have any power,
I think it depends on how the mayor shows up
and if people are saying the mayor doesn't have any power…
That's because we probably have a mayor that’s showing up in that way.
No rivalry, full love and respect here.
I'm just saying… -That's your thoughts.
Yeah, that is not true
when you have £17 billion a year
and when you design the strategy and when you dictate
ultimately what London should look and feel like over a tenure.